fundamentally man artists he makes their
sculptures move I do kinetic art so I'm
not you know a roboticist as such use of
random way of going about things and it
is definitely my way and maybe not the
way that someone else might do it I was
working on restoring a robot could sigan
which was um the first foreign humanoid
robots who come into England and I was
just halfway through was storing that
and and I know that science reason
wanted it in the exhibition and then
they Ben Russell contacted me to UM to
do a complete is that replica of Eric
and said what are they interested in
doing it and now me I thought it's a
challenge and I yeah went for him and I
think the hardest things going to be
making it an exact replica cuz it some
bit so as a nice I quite like to change
because some bits to me a city they
don't know right but I will keep it from
exact for the sake of the project and
yeah it's going to be a challenge
this is stage one and and it's basically
the armature stage where you build the
mainframe and the serf they're basically
the robot skeleton and and this involves
but making it sturdy but lightweight and
putting in these these motors which are
called linear actuators and they're all
twelve volt which keeps it nice and safe
and um and they're nice and quiet do a
smooth job so this is the arm they're
normally used for things like hospital
beds or dentist's chairs where you need
some smooth quiet motion in fact
sometimes they used to like even just
opening windows you can't reach and I
like them because they're twelve volt
and they're pretty powerful and I sort
of I tend to shy away from from mains
voltage because it's just it's too
dangerous for me and this one here which
will be controlling the head this is a
radio control server which would be
normally used for steering a radio
controlled car or something like that or
maybe aeroplane wings these these two
big motors here they have to take all of
Eric's weight and they're there to make
him stand up and that's they're quite
slow but they're very powerful because a
lot of weight on him
so they're they still come up to here
and he stands upright that this one here
is his torso and it that straightens his
back as he stands up and these two here
are going to do his arms I'm going to
show you in a minute and these ones do
his elbows so this should raise the arm
up and down
so looking good and this should bring
the elbow in so this is another good
thing about 12 volt is you can't really
electrocute yourself that's all smooth
and on the battery charge of the Y use
the spatula it's got little amp meter in
it so it tells me if if there's any sort
of resistance that's going to cause a
problem later on goes down again
[Music]
beautiful everyone has their different
ways of working don't they I mean some
people draw it out meticulously on paper
and work that way and they're happy
working that way but for me I'm I do
everything by eye this is the the head
this is the basic eye movement this is
another radio control server and this
will this moves the eyes from side to
side and we're going to have some leds
in here so they'll be lit up and the
mouth area stuff here and we're gonna
have another sort of sound to light LED
system here which means here's flash
when he um when he speaks in time with
his voice I think the original one had
sparks coming out but I'm I think we're
not gonna do that cuz it's not
particularly appropriate for the
exhibition but um yeah so this is the
eye mechanism
it's almost like I said radio control
car steering setup
we're just of moves these would normally
be the wheels but I'm I'm using it to
turn the eyes and then I've sort of
tried to get a basic sat bone structure
for him to put his head put his the
aluminium on which and this it's tricky
because I don't know if you can see but
like he's got this they've given him a
jaw bone which is weird and then this
other bit of neck comes up the back
there so yeah to redo that a couple of
times
splitting the head on here and you can
see how his guys take it starting to
take form the whole robot like I've got
ideas of
there's a character I think that will
emerge out of the build in the end and
there I mean Eric that was described as
the quintessential gentleman I believe
it English gentleman so I imagine he's
going to be quite as a dignified
character which means the way we're
giving him any shakes and yeah he's
meant to be the race of polite and
rather posh I believe so yeah we're CV
keeps that regal touch
workshop for about 15 years now and is a
great feeling you coming in in the
morning and he closed the door behind
you I just love being in that frame of
mind so shutting the outside world away
or just getting creative is it's a great
feeling and it feels a real privilege to
be able to do that on a daily basis for
Erick's basic movements I used 12 volt
linear actuators and they simply push in
and out so you can use them for your
arms going up and down elbows moving etc
once there it's all wired up and ready
to go you run through each motor test so
that that's more working and then you
open up this program called VSA which is
where you program the movements in a
sequence which normally involves moving
a few motors all at the same time and
getting their timing exactly right
I'm guilty of them taking my work home
with me I still have a lot of so waking
up 4:00 in the morning and sort of
plotting and working working on how to
do things but I don't actually mind it
um because it is quite a quite good time
to do it and yeah and I buy time I have
breakfast sort of worked out how I'm
going to do that day
so the next stage is it's the stage that
I'm probably most uncomfortable with
it's not it's not something that I've
done before and I know that it's a it's
a kind of process of trial and error
which means because I'm gonna real
drawings to go by it's all going to be
done by eye and it's going to be my
interpretation of how I see that piece
of Eric the process will involve them
getting a bit of card and covering Eric
and the piece of Eric that I want to
cover with the aluminium fitting the
card cutting it out
laying it onto the aluminium cutting the
aluminium out then offering the
aluminium up on to Eric and and just
keep on taking it on and off and
trimming it and cutting it until it fits
and that's right so the next bit is just
getting rid of the sharp edges so use
one of these just to round them off so
now you have to bend it into shape and
this is quite a haphazard procedure
because there's just it's just
completely random to be honest I get a
rough idea of where it's gonna Bend
and then he you know you've had the
frilly bits at the end to cover the
rough edges right now he's still metal I
think and when he moves let's see a
little bit of so on so this is the
wrapper unit which I guess is kind of um
Eric's brain it's where you I program
all the movement sequences into him and
we can trigger them independently and it
also has his voice in it and yeah very
simple unit that I use in most of my
robots actually it runs on DMX or
independently depending on what you want
to do with it
oh hello there - his body is all
different I'm all full of wires and
motors and fancy 21st century
electronics into the police gears in the
nineteen twenties right where was I oh
yes hello my name is Alec and I'm
thrilled to be alive
morning all I'm just polishing Eric
before I'm the chance for comes to pick
him up and take him to the London
Science Museum yes
he's off today and um we're gonna miss
him around here there was an enormous
pressure to to get it right you know he
was is a replica and I had to look like
him and function like him I think you
know especially members of the family
from the original creator you know they
wanted it to be the same and be good and
hopefully you know I've done it justice
being a robot builder to help create the
original robot is quite something yeah
I've been here 15 years and within those
15 years I've created over 20 or more
robots and yeah it's always good to see
one finished
you